welcome to this video pop while 29 this
is Poland right yep keep screwing this
up with Indonesia but okay I've played
him quite a bit but not much recently I
have a good score here seven and a half
out of nine ok let's do something else
there in the twins I'm sorry in the new
indian classical not knight c6 but this
line so aged six then c5 is an
interesting way to play cakes there
should be six that has been recently
played a [ __ ] and top-level chess and
blackheads pretty decent results it
looks very normal yeah it's quite
surprising that it took a long time to
figure out that this is actually a good
line okay so I'm taking and playing
before LG 5 that's 11 point the very
quick development I'm out for 94 and 96
c5 is thinking quite a bit him
the P sacrifice really shouldn't work
yep and so here we go and I'm not
totally sure that night see 5 or is it
rook c8 or something night c5b for looks
a bit irritating
I but i have no i don't have a dad i can
actually take g3 and then night you fall
again for and for Queen f6 and things
like that oh that's interesting he just
plays a slow move here so Queen B 6 I
guess or not it still has reformed or
Bishop f5 actually what is he doing
laughter Bishop f5 that's very
interesting move let's try that so it's
going back Queen B 6 now is still before
hmm gee I don't know it's it would have
been better if I knew this line and not
have to make things up here with a board
yeah before is still kind of irritating
nope not going for that isn't night b3
now interesting night be three
okay I keep overlooking moves here
didn't think about that one at all I
don't know if it is good but I didn't
see it Queenie five check is a funny
little more but not not sure if it is
doing much
I take a one-night f5 don't have those
chicks
Jim no yeah okay that's a way to lose
the game black there's I wanted to check
on 85 of course Jeff what a silly game I
mean the game wasn't silly it was okay
it was a silly silly way to lose okay he
went he and I wanted to check their I
mean I really didn't know what's going
on it's totally totally one out of this
position this is what I was thinking
Teague's takes and then there then from
here yeah I've got 92 I've got 9 p-3 I
don't know the computer quite funny d
gives equal equal equal to 0 0 0 with
this move I have my doubts that looks
dangerous does this the SAS dangerous
this kind of thing but what about
earlier what about earlier i felt like i
should be quite okay i think they go
Bishop d7 ah yeah this is the move that
I forgot Bishop d7 I had to study this
while ago i forgot about this idea the
computer is giving this now I mean not
like I'm winning or whatever but this is
I forgot the idea this is the idea okay
well okay this is not bad but it isn't
the usual way to play as I'm just just
blundering the Queen okay I felt it is
still interesting to show this this half
game let's say because of this opening
line which is quite interesting Black
has a very active piece play for his
structural deficit and I think he is
quite ok I analyzed this a little bit a
while back like a couple of month ago
with a student but obviously i forgot
the continuation okay well mouth slip
ended this but it was still interesting
thanks for watching